hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast challenges of natural
preservative application I am Judy or
arc of lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event leopards
calm is the leading scientific social
networking site and we are proud to
bring you this interactive web seminar
for more information visit us at lab
roots com here's how this presentation
works we want to hear from you questions
comments and even answers can be
submitted via the green Q&A button at
the lower left of your screen will try
to get to everyone but if not we'll make
sure to follow up with you by e-mail you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
can't hear or see this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button at the top right or the
Q&A button in the lower left I would now
like to introduce today's speaker dr.
Philip guys dr. guys joined the Procter
& Gamble Company P&G in 1981 as
divisional microbiologist for product
quality disinfectant development and
study of household and skin microbial
ecology its subsequent work as scientist
and manager focused on preservation
method development design and operation
of sanitary manufacturing systems and
microbial ecology associated with
underarm odor dandruff toilets oils and
bathroom mildew through his career dr.
geist manage microbiology efforts for
cosmetics over-the-counter drugs
household products and beverage and food
business units of PNG he also carry hard
surface cleaner technical brand
management responsibilities as and his
coat inventor for a number of domestic
and international patents in addition
dr. guys managed federal and state
regulatory and environmental affairs in
2011 Phil retired from P&G and founded
guys microbiological quality in
affiliation with biological sciences and
in virus services of the advanced
testing laboratory of Cincinnati Ohio
he's an international consultant from
microbiological quality of OTC drug
cosmetic household and industrial
products and cultural properties is also
an instructor for the microbiology and
cell science department of the
university of florida i will now attend
it over to dr. Giese thanks very much
thank you I'm going to talk about
natural preservatives and give me some
practical perspective I work in this
field for a long time and this is a an
area that I'll explain to you it's
become very interesting very very
important to the growing market my talk
today is going to be directed it's
fairly small medium and large
manufacturers that so much to do it
yourselfers unless so much of those
tractors who sell their stuff and
various spheres i'm looking more to
those guys are going to have high high
output large volume production and bring
the issues they need to worry about that
need to be concerned with when they look
at natural preservatives I'll talk about
is first why and what's the market what
is the need for natural preservative
isn't and how big a market market is it
I'll talk about what is natural or the
basis for the claim and the materials
identities and both the identities and
concerns I'll go through a number of
materials not it's not an exhaustive
list I put it together mainly to show
you what's out there what are the major
elements after and what you have to
watch out for you because these are not
direct plug-ins for the current
synthetics I'll go through these
comparisons and explain why these are
plugins there's a number of issues
number of considerations you have to
make and lastly I'll give you an
overview sort of due diligence as you
pursue natural preservatives though I
won't discuss them there's a long list
of references you'll be able to access
at the end of this top that may be
useful to you they're all technical
references it may surprise some of you
but there is a fair scientific
literature things or preservation and
related events so why what what's the
big deal with at the natural
preservatives well there's a number of
factors
driving as part of the market in a sense
there's a lot of any chemical and poor
science that's driving at this there's
various NGOs or non-governmental
organizations that have expressed great
concern for current synthetic
preservatives there's a lot of bloggers
out there to repeat this information and
and they're on all sides of a political
event except fence the natural is safe
and moral there's true believers
herbalists especially in some DIY eyes
and tractors see the synthetic
preservatives is very inappropriate and
there's their science and the industry
has criticized as science especially
that a belief of darbari out of the
university of reading in the UK that
questions the safety of current
preservatives here's an example of the
anti chemical true believers this is at
a very recent otherwise pretty good
article and kind of herbal cosmetics and
cosmeceuticals I encourage you to read
it not for this statement not for the
bias of the art are authored but more so
for the range of information they talk
about in there but I'll direct your
attention to this quote this is taken
directly from the paper it's unqualified
it says compared to beauty front that
other beauty products natural cosmetics
are safe to use hypoallergenic and
tested and proven by dermatologists at
you safe to use any time in any way this
is unsupported by any references is a
standalone statement on its face it's
obviously incorrect there's no way that
every herbal cosmetic in the world has
been tested by dermatologists and and
saying anything is safe to use anytime
anywhere it's probably not accurate but
but always motivation aside there is a
growing market business on a product for
the natural products especially the
naturally preserved products here are
some statements and these are these are
some old ones the 2010 doesn't seem that
old but these are when the market is
still growing and and the information
here's as a growing market for these
place or the ultra natural brands and it
was expectedly account for about 17 form
four percent of the industry by 2030
from five percent of 2010 so how's that
fair let's go to more recent stop
declining company surveillance planning
company is is a commercial concern that
does market research it's probably the
gold standard of market research in 2014
they saw seven percent sail club for
natural cosmetics with national
preservatives versus two percent for the
overall segment of cosmetics
transparency marketing estimates that it
will be a 13 billion dollar market by
2008 I'm sorry 2018 and that's what
we're seeing some major retailers
questioning the use of the of the
traditional synthetic preservatives but
so what is now there's the FTC give us a
definition that's irrelevant doesn't it
doesn't define natural law what it says
is if a reasonable consumer could
interpret a natural claim is
representing to the product occasional
audition ingredients then you have to be
able to prove them and be clear to that
proof has to come from the guy this
marketing not from your supplier your
suppliers it is natural you take his
word for it it may be in trouble you're
the one that's responsible to make a
little prove ended question in here it's
more prescriptive I offer the definition
here from the council review their
guidelines specify that it has to be
obtained by physical methods extrusion
or filtration or microbiological and
enzymatic methods own so you're getting
more constrained in Europe in the US you
have to prove it but it doesn't say how
you answer but in both cases if your
challenge if you the market is
challenging you are a responsible group
not the supplier not any button not
anybody else so let's just get into this
before we do them I want to emphasize
one important element the preservatives
are very important probably the most
importantly breeding in a cosmetic or
even in an OTC cosmetic admitted cases
the reason is it is the sole ingredient
and it exclusively for a safety purpose
even the guys who use synthetic
preservatives and those are still the
big major part of the preservatives that
are using cosmetics they don't use them
because they want to they're expensive
molecules they get it a lot black but
they use them because they
they have to because they serve an
affirmative risk assessment
preservatives survey confirm risk
assessment that the manufacturer can say
this product is safe to use it's not a
matter of putting in a preserving and
saying I've got to preserve it in there
it'll probably work it's an affirmative
thing you have to be able to prove it if
questioned and the consequences are
really serious it certainly there's
regulatory action and nobody wants a
recall but they're clear cases of
infection that a pumpkin cosmetics that
have caused blindness and even death
that sounds very serious but here's one
I called on the literature fairly
recently this is a issue that developed
in in the Saudi Arabia and here's this
is not uncommon for the third world this
is a profit there is a knockoff of a
very famous domestic shampoo for babies
and I will name it but this is a
knockout they knocked it off they
reproduce it in their own factory and
sold it unfortunately it became
contaminated with bacteria with a
veteran called serratia marcescens it's
sick and three of these babies and one
of them actually died from the effects
and this is consistent with what happens
with contaminated shampoos like this or
contaminant cosmetics in general you
have you have a sensitive population is
to do these the immunocompromised
population here is the kids here's the
babies it could be folks with chronic
diseases like diabetes or cystic
fibrosis rate folks on on therapy to
reduce their immune system perhaps on
cancer therapy or any rejection theory
or on some of the new drugs that you
seen advertised for from your matata
brightest or even psoriasis on TV the
estimate currently is that there's over
twenty five percent of the United States
population is considered in a
compromised and especially sensitive
this kind of contamination so this is
not a trivial matter as preservative is
a very important ingredient I the most
important ingredient and any cosmetic so
we're going to talk about we're going to
talk about natural preserves so I'm
going to give you a test it's obviously
a take home test because I can rage on
I want you to look at these molecules
here these materials and decide which
one of these occurs naturally I'll give
you a couple of seconds just go down
there and say what's your the curs
natural just for information the iso
files alums are synthetic chemicals is a
quick answer that are found probably in
most of the shampoos and surfactant
products like not body washes and hand
wash products in the world the most
common crucially you had a chance to
look at it here's the answer these are
the ones in red are the ones that don't
occur naturally methylparaben it can be
found flowers berries and bacteria from
allied it's it's a common biological
molecule again in very low levels
grapefruit seed extract Lee the darling
of so many bloggers is not natural even
as supply this non Metro is a chemical
derivative of a natural mature now the
iso files alone the courts are not
natural there they're a very common
synthetic reserve tea tree oil benzoic
acid BYE MOM little are indeed naturally
occurring returns the next question I'm
going to ask you is which of these
occurs which of these in its primary
commercial supplies is natural and you
see it's only tea tree oil of course
methylparaben says is a used commercial
is synthetic chemicals famous for mal
nah I have mentioned grapefruit seed
extract a thing not natural as a
chemical derivative and even at that it
probably isn't even an honest with her
preservative use a turn there are a
number of papers maybe eight from around
the world and choosing including one
from the United States by the USDA the
report the grapefruit extract is
adulterated with various synthetic
molecules in bed a bio sites like
pyramids like triclosan like various
quaternary ammonium compounds uses
disinfectants and in primary commercial
supply benzoic acid even biology to lift
all our synthesize this easier and
cheaper to make them synthetically it
should be to make exactly the same
chemicals but we're not talking about
synthetic so we're going to talk about
natural preservatives and I'm an editor
of a journal that the toxin on bio
degradation and I get a lot of these
articles a lot of
to talk about natural preservatives and
if I went to the list these are the ones
you might find honey salt and water
removal or roll a claw direction the
botanicals alcohol organic acids he
laterz enzyme systems and what we call
antibiotics or things that inhibit
bacterial that obtained from other
bacteria or other organisms I'm not
going to talk about honey salt and water
removal too much especially honey and so
those are not practical for for
cosmetics at all so to give the natural
preserves one of the biggest thing
people talk about our bot our botanical
of these are botanical origin and here
just a list of some of the plants from
which people have said we've gotten the
materials that are effective as
preservatives I put grapefruit seed
extract in theirs is a highlight because
again that's a very questionable
material but there's a number of others
you can see them here and you could
probably if you're familiar with the
industry you probably know some of these
things yourself one of this is the
botanical oils the essential so-called
essential oils and use your typically
obtained by some kind this hydro or
steam distillation you can also obtain
it by extraction with organic solvents
like ethanol or hexane or even
supercritical fluid extraction with co2
in each of by each of these different
extraction methods or the United
distillation you get a different set of
chemicals and that's important too
because the botanical extracts can vary
considerably based on the way they
obtained what you saw as hydro
distillation would give you one set of
panels if you extracted with ethanol or
use co2 critical point extraction you
get enough different set of chemicals so
the extract that you use you must make
sure you have a consistent supply in
terms of the way it's obtained to get a
consistent supply a combination of
chemicals that you do the right activity
so what is it but these are not magic
botanical extracts whatever they are
other essential oils whether these are
not an edge they have chemicals in them
biologically oriented counter originated
chemicals use various hydrocarbons and
other chemicals that a responsible for
the active and here is some of the major
sets or terpenoids and aromatics
I put in read some of the ones that I
believe that it have fairly good
activity the turkey knee all the
geranium the eucalyptol and your column
eucalyptol can also be obtained in
quantity by commercial sources by
synthetic surfaces the aromatics like
veneto alcohol and benzoic on Eugene off
by Morrow and others like menthol Aspen
bark which is really salicylic acid and
that aside now finesse cockerel people
often ask me for replacements for
various synthetic chemicals and I i
mentioned spin at the wrong time like
here's a peek tradition you can see on
the left side is staph aureus it's a
gram-positive bacterium and theres been
alot hawk in this auger in fact that
info often what is auger is a commercial
logger that you isolate gram-positive
bacteria because it inhibits
gram-negative bacteria this serratia
marcescens on the right is the same
microb contaminated that shampoo that
unfortunately killed a kitten in saudi
arabia but this is one of the ones that
you might consider perhaps it in
replacing phenoxyethanol or some of the
other chemicals that are used to inhibit
and kill the back the grand- factory
Vanessa alcohol does come with a fairly
strong none strong over those are
characteristically sort of a rosary in
fact is called Rose ether and the
commercials so what about botanical if
you had to worry about if you had to use
those things and you wanted to make sure
your product was reserved correctly so
you didn't kill the baby what would you
be interested well you the process
variables how does it obtained with was
in heat was it what was the process was
it a solvent because you want this same
set of chemicals every time and these
are these things are all in the
literature that's Richard you'll find me
on this time the plant Park the
different combinations even though it
may be rosemary you may get a different
set of chemicals if you abstract the
leaves or the stems of the roots with
the delano a stage if you young versus
maturely to issue a different set of
chemicals the season of harvest in the
region of cultivation if you harvest it
in the springer you may get a different
set of chemicals
message on the verge we're reaching the
cultivation you may have different bio
types of rosemary in different parts of
the world and this different chemicals
of the product and pre and post harvest
control dennis is real important lots of
reports are out there about that
indicates pre and post harvest control
is not adequate pre-harvest control
means use of pesticides and these
pesticides are in the plans and will be
extracted with the essential oils so you
have to make sure that you don't have
pesticides gonna leave the bar and the
same thing with something called
aflatoxin it's produced by fungi it's a
fairly effective percentage at higher
levels and a real high levels it'll
knock out your Luger and knock after the
kidneys it's in all the grains at you
dated peanuts and peanut butter possum
but you don't want in your cosmetics and
again the present symptoms but because
you saw as you probably have heard the
pictures you extract so what how would
you do this this has always been an
issue that i found talking to some of
the folks would supply essentials I've
said you know I'd really like to have
fine chemical analysis that shows
consistency from from batch the bats
because i'll make this product for years
hopefully and sell it for a lot of
people i want to make sure that
preservative works every time i talked
to various Orville listen and I
understand their their viewpoint but it
doesn't serve my purpose what I've often
heard is no I know about the insurance I
know when they're good I know when
they're contending I know what the
composition is because I'm an herbalist
I've been doing this my whole life I can
smell it I nobody feel that this is good
stuff and that may work for them but it
doesn't work for me because I work in a
business that or I have to answer the
FDA it's mike reserved and i have to
enter to my management initely to my
customers and mike and their parents if
the preservative doesn't work in it
hurts their kids or it's one of their
runs so what else about American
commercial botanical I look pretty
costly they have product effects they
usually carry odors often color and
texture and they have chemicals that
affects stability to prom I mentioned to
the peninsula
alcohol so it's kind of like road I'll
music and indeed that may be something
you don't want to have your time Rose
isn't bad and then I Mina may not be the
smelled of the older you're trying to
impart it so competition is variable and
supplier information is knowing straight
what you really want to know is is
enough data may be using GC data that
tells you if the actives are they're the
ones that maybe I hadn't read and that
they're looking at a certain level and
you want to make sure the purity is the
impurities are concerned about their
potential results you want to make sure
mycotoxin is not there and pesticide and
either these are Jennifer adjustable
justifiable requests and you should make
these requests and get these data if
you're using the commercial botanical
extracts so let's move on to the
alcohols you guys are familiar with
epilogue Oh certain benzyl alcohol is a
fairly good conservative and also as
emit days can be found in natural source
and as I mentioned phonetic on it
doesn't have a lot of ethanol as a
standalone preserve we typically League
about 20 percentage that is the critical
cutoff point we have some effect down to
five percent so that's a let them be
combined with other preservatives nidhi
give you an effect down to as low as 5
percent less than five percent you're
not going to get mentioned in the fact
benzoin but that's author are pretty
good they're used levels are you
typically less than 1% the primary
efficacy is against gram-negative so you
might not be so good against some of the
grand positives user bacteria like staph
aureus but they have cost and if they
said the phenytoin has odor and benzyl
has a little bit of a little too let's
talk about organic acids this isn't also
a fairly common source of preservatives
that people consider for natural rocks I
made a list here but the ones I putting
red or probably the ones that are more
active sort of it benzoic salicylic mu z
ib is its soluble salt sodium or
potassium salts reason for that is the
answers are not solved soluble at the
typical pH is where you have to Adam so
you take forever making it they getting
to go into some loose and the cost from
a natural source or a lot greater than
sign that the costume synthetic sources
they have limited efficacy but the
contamination risks you face in industry
are anywhere from about three but it's
fairly acidic to 11 which is fairly
basic the organic acid efficacy is at
best for a 5.5 and typically below for
4.5 so anything else that's not fairly
acidic it's not going to get much
benefit from organic acids and what they
do affect is the effect fun John you
smooth some bacteria like staph aureus
but not suitable it's not grand- so much
I mentioned before that those organic
alcohols effect grand- well these affect
the other venture upon joining some
bacteria typically eating sure have
limited usefulness so we use them with a
different ditional preservative and they
too can have a product of X color pH
changes because you won't even load and
solubility if you aren't able to get it
to go to solution remember you always
use a salt with assassin let's talk
about some key letters you may have
noticed a lot of commercial cosmetics
use ETA is ethylene diamine tetra CS
it's not a preservative on its own but
what it does it has a big affinity or a
love for calcium and magnesium and iron
and it makes other preservatives work
better the idea is that the EDA tdg
especially takes the magnesium out of
the cell wrong of the bacterium and that
make a net cell walls less stable for
the preservative you get in there it
also gathers up the iron and these men
made these bacteria all these fungi or
tire irons with their sins for their
considerate not sitter of course the
brute to be able to breathe recited
crumbs so if they if their irons
gathered up and stop they can't breathe
very so you might consider these things
as replacements for EDTA that health
preservatives work there they're not
primary preservatives and oak Italian
some of you may be familiar with that I
received I then received to that that
have come in contaminate with bacteria
itself so you have to be aware of as
well and again as with a lot of these
things but complexes needy pigment or
color let's talk about some antibiotics
I'll try not to mention some of the some
of the ones you're familiar with two
then I'm talking brand names but some of
the ones used in foods or miss and that
myosin and there's one that's confidence
being used a lot now and talked about a
lot in the natural preservative is a
peptide from radish and kimchi
fermentation a nest nissen madam icing
are called her grass foods which means
generally recognized as safe which is
good of course these things have limited
efficacy especially versus gram-negative
bacteria which is again the same kind of
bacterium to kill the kid in Saudi
Arabia the solubility can be pretty
limited the levels and needed are fairly
high in the common thieves are not not
inexpensive forgive your fairly
expensive converters there is a dolt
eration concern with the last one f5
from radish and kimchi permit it's a
single article the supplier of this
material claims it was published at the
request of a competitor but it was from
the university so that question is still
open it hasn't been confirmed yet in any
kind of literature let's talk about one
enzyme-based this is sort of equivocal
as a natural certainly the enzyme is
natural some of the chemicals you have
to add to make the enzyme work I'm not
natural but there are very low levels
this is available commercially from from
arch chemical the Cascade is limp is
initiated by the excellent glucose
oxidase and it goes through a series of
reactions they generate an antimicrobial
component it is a very narrow pH ring
for the six you can find this in some of
the natural branch and proves especially
and if a loser substrate overtime losses
activity over time and with any dilution
it will lose efficacy the idea is that
when you've opened the bottle you an
oxygen in it starts to reaction and it
produces some of these the antimicrobial
component that knocks out the bar you
close the bottle and it doesn't and the
rest of it is not exhausted so it's only
a dentist's relatively limited shelf
life and if you dilute it you're going
to probably get bugs in there and
leather on the group excuse me on the
green post-its an interesting
preservative an issue is commercial and
buy something rare so here there's a 12
Cochran up for the tannic
especially the extraction oils organic
acids glucose oxidase biological key
leaders and antibiotics in my experience
I've used none of these vital signs
unuse them together and there's a
something called a hurdle concept which
which envisions with the idea that that
you're sending up a bunch of hurdles for
the bacteria to jump over the
contaminate your product you can't hit
him with a baseball bat right a bat
might be can with the current synthetics
because the botanicals e these other
things just aren't that strong so you
send up a whole bunch of so the bacteria
jumping role of these hurdles gets worn
out and doesn't survive and one that you
might consider and I put a picture here
on the right side it's packaged patchy
packaging will help you preserve our
crop and actually it's the ultimate
through certificate that you can make a
new and oh she probably wouldn't need
preservatives but what it does is lower
the amount of bacteria and fungi that
can get inside your chronic and
challenge nikki messy so what do we know
about natural preservatives I talked
about I'll talk about is the external
need various subject see a safety
regulatory affairs in the context of
each of these into but first let's
compare it to the equity of traditional
conservatives so these are the parabens
the iso files alone from a life of
leisure ETA the things that have been
around for the last 50 52 almost 100
years the competition impurity is willna
these are synthetic chemicals are
consistent they're made in plants you
know exactly what the new impurities are
you know exactly what the consistency is
you made to specification or their
concentration we know that stable direct
and indirect on the formula we did we've
had decades of working with this we know
that we know their stability and
emulsions and their effect on products
typically the industry at large looks
for a three-year stability day and
that's my experience as well we look to
bring stability to preserve so it's
effective through three years of
consumer use because actually four years
from making and process these things
that they said before not linked
interested so much what's going on
BL defending DUI folks but the folks
that are manufacturing in wrong and when
you make a cosmetic you often have
transient effects of any different
ingredients you have heat and some
ingredient combinations there's
transient effects of acid and base so
you know what with these traditions you
know where to add it it's not it's not a
mystery you add certain things when it's
cool sort of things when it's hot and
you know where to add there's so much
experience lioness and validation this
is an important element and it's one
it's difficult for a lot of folks to
understand the major manufacturers have
all done consumer use the validate that
a preservative system developed and
tested and and proven to be effective in
the laboratory by their testing is also
effective in the hands of the consumer
so they might put thousands of units out
let consumers use it for the regular
period of time and get them old back and
look for bacteria and that's how they
validate their test but there's also
validation and manufacturing it's sort
of a affected one because you can't do
the same thing you did for consumers but
if you can make a system that passes
your preservative test over and over and
over again for year after year in your
manufacturing facility that's effective
validation say well I've got to have a
preservative manufacturing because I'm
not making it sterile conditions and
I've made all these years after a past
line test so I think it's pretty much
talents and then if the last element is
important again for the guys that are
manufacturing and marketing and gold
there's minimal and consistent have been
five development cycle and what they
mean is when you innovate when you bring
out your products it takes a lot of time
sometimes to make sure a new
preservative the one you have no
experience with is safe and effective
but one you've used for years and years
like the parabens like the ISO plasma on
different online releasers you know the
bumps you know the week and you can be
pretty sure that it'll pass all the
tests so you can never have everything
going as rapidly as possible in your
products to market so let's compare this
to the natural preservatives
the composition impurity Alba the record
here is limited to none you're going to
have to discover this yourself when
you're with your natural preservative
source you're not going to have Dow
Chemical in Monsanto providing using
extra features you're going to have much
smaller guys who may not have it the
chemical capability of telling you
what's in there and so you have to find
a way to get the composition purity that
you need to know one to make sure it
works and two to make sure you're not
bring anything bad that my purchase
consumer steadily as I said we have
three years in our in our products and
synthetic products to demonstrate
preservative stability again for your
natural preserves you're going to happen
in this case by case and this you're
going to do it by every formula and
because formulas may change and you
won't know because you have no
experience with it how a changed formula
is going to be affected by the grocery
or vice versa you may have heard period
after open PA oh this is not it I want
to emphasize this is not a
get-out-of-jail-free card I've
encountered some companies have seen it
as much they've had natural
preservatives that hadn't been stable so
what they did was he was stable only in
for three months they put their PA 08
three times and I want you to think
about it because there's a there's two
major flaws here one is the PA 0 doesn't
tell the consumer a whole lot because
that product might have been made six
months or even a year beforehand before
it got to the consumer so you so it's
for sable for three months you can't
presume that it's going to be that clock
starts when the consumer opened that
bottle and more importantly all the
literature and there is published
literature and you'll find that in the
references at the end say the consumers
don't care about them they don't look at
dates like pho or exploration they use
it when they want to use it and they use
it as they want to eat and lastly time
is not good element I know many of you
heard that mascara shouldn't be used
more than six months well in my
experience the preservative stable and
mascaras for the typical 33 years six
months the preservative still they are
working mascaras are contaminated not
fine time not but by the consumer you
spanner
by people spinning in the kind of scary
licking that are spitting on the lawn or
doing other things that adulterate
probably leaving the car too long aha
not by time i'm just going to know you
here for process you got to figure out
where you're going to add this natural
concern it's a stable if you handed in
the hot hot links you have to add a cold
if you had a cold will go in a solution
well an efficacy this is the ability
that preserves the product this is case
by case the potential for contamination
is going to be greater here so you may
have to have greater manufacturing
controls than you have before because
you made it with things that you knew
were going to like the baseball now
we're going to knock down the bucks here
you may have a series of steps not going
alone and will your current
manufacturing controls be enough to
protect the Prime and lastly consumer
protection again you know that those
synthetic the baseball bats work really
well to protect yourself it's this
hurdle product kind of protecting
centers in all honesty you guys should
really probably do some consumer use
sense but that's what a lot of folks are
filling out in the major major cosmetic
marketing world as they try to
understand whether they can use natural
preservatives or I'll turn now of course
efficiency the impact I'm proud of em no
psycho is going to be very significant
because we're your parent in your mouth
I deletion may have been a great
preservative so much so that you can
count on and working every time so you
can do with some rapid testing to make
sure it appeared to be consistent
through some chemical analysis on on the
active to make sure that you're still
there and go right to mark and then go
back and develop a new innovative
product for natural preservatives you're
going to do a lot more work to make sure
it works and that work means time and
money that's a more time to do it it's
going to impact your product development
cycle so you can be less efficient and
you going to take longer to bring new
products to market compliance this is a
tough one because there's a lot of
different approaches here financial
preservatives comparing it to the
current synthetics is a big difference
in the US as you probably know the
responsibility is no market for say
he's responsible for the safety of
preserved everything in the crime it is
if he hasn't shown it safe he has to say
so on the loop well in the US we had the
cosmetic ingredient we have a lot of
research but behind the current
synthetics that say they're safe and use
in Europe and most of the rest of the
world there are positive lists you can
use preservatives that are on this list
you use cosmetic directive is learning
you can use forgeries a tireless and so
basically there's a set of maybe five or
six maybe seven or eight synthetic
preservatives that are used consistently
throughout the world these are these are
the ones that work and no new procedures
are coming to market and that's why the
current the current marketers are so
concerned because nobody's bringing new
features or samar and these synthetics
are disappearing or people want them to
disappear let's compare them to natural
persons again in the u.s. you can use
what you want to but you're responsible
for the safety of the crime and the
safety of that preservative and if
somebody asks you for the data you need
to have those it's not enough the same
light supplier setting is safe you need
to have baited it says it's safe on
these positive lists every place else
offer you guys you're not going to find
many of these listed especially the
botanicals and you're going to have to
decide how you will comply I've seen
some place some folks say preservatives
or the secondary benefit really running
who these things because their perfume
actors are they serve other function
I've seen one term called microbial
blocking technology which tried a belief
an S the positive must but again if you
don't have these on the positive list
and you're using its preserved you're
ready cuz you're right you're not in
compliance with with the rest of the
world other than you guys and they said
please don't count on the PA o to cover
your cover the lack of stability here's
a citation to that article I was talking
about this these guys look at expired
makeup including mascara to see if
people actually followed through they
put expiration date and they didn't
people did what they did before they
before there was any exploration they
didn't read it it didn't care so you're
responsible i said to to your consumers
for only times for the natural reserves
and there are some other elements that
have come out that we've seen the
recalls contaminated products are very
very serious economic then they're more
serious because you might be putting in
similar service I know that's what you
guys are worried but the government is
also concerned they want to protect
their citizens and they'll find
certainly the FDA and in the rape
actually Colin Europe are well known
recalled vehicles but in every country
in the world is a very polishing the
natural preservatives are what is being
called though very few recalls are are
happening in the u.s. because most of
the market is so it affects those few
recalls you'll find our associate with
natural or terms of desert on firstly in
Europe there's a lot of recons and
almost all are associated with natural
products a resource like by these
authors it recalls the microphones for
tentative products and this is just 2008
and it's gotten worse since then they
went through all these recalls and they
said it'll take all these projects are
natural products including some organic
compounds and it's what they theorized
was it's not just the fact that it has a
natural preservative but because their
combined with other than natural
ingredients and these natural
ingredients or bring a PI over and I in
the normal way of making product such as
it normally classic when you have
chemical ingredients you can line these
chemical ingredients or not they'll have
a bio that will bring invention for the
natural products with them with a
somewhat weaker natural preservative you
bring in natural materials and these
natural materials you often have a lot
of bacteria that put a greater burden on
the product and they're going to have
otherwise so a lot of these recalls are
associated with natural products again
these fall back on the the items of
knowing what your active is in that
natural mature making sure it's at that
quantity controlling controlling your
manufacturing in this case you have to
make sure your raw materials are really
clean don't bring in bacteria to so it's
so the three
elements your your manufacturing
controls your preservation and the
packaging all have to be modified if
you're going to use natural
preservatives so compliance maybe just
send it sorry I make dunk the business
so what is it let's talk about safety
the equity of current synthetics
extensive database these have been
around for a long time they've been
reused by its cir regulatory bodies and
then look at our all sorts of ways the
FD a-- has no issues with the currently
the current synthetic preservatives the
safety issues identified a large beta
son David experiment models irrelevant
to use or just for science you may if
you search the last you find this
innumerable references citing pyramids
cause west campus totally bogus so
lethal so what do you have a natural
again they're perceived as say why
because they're natural but the data may
be in fact usually is very limited you
may have contaminations I did it for
panicles the pesticides the mycotoxin
even micro others there's sensitizers
cinnamaldehyde enzymes can be
sensitizers and the issue is really when
you get into it are similar to whether a
lunch with some back here just a couple
of references that are again making the
citations in the ad the nudity density
of effectively arose model on mem am
cells in vivo this is the kind of stuff
that that has been used to criticize
synthetic loser the situation to
sublethal concentration of tea tree oil
reduces susceptibility to antibiotics so
this article suggests that the more you
speaker on the more you're going to have
bacteria resistant to antibiotics and
the last one here prepubertal gano nasty
a link the lavender and t3 these are
young boys we were using palm oil and
are using a pomade on their hair that
had a high amounts of Lander and tea
tree oil and it caused them to grow
breasts that's what the article [ __ ] so
the constants of the concept of natural
means safe is pretty questionable sounds
good but it doesn't it's not supported
by
data all other factors well does any
preservatives I said you know the
practice sexual you know those well the
account it isn't a product development
cycle in the environment impact of
production is regulated these are
chemical plants like dal and Monsanto
and the larger if their compliance with
EPA emissions standards both air
emissions and water emissions they know
what comes out they control that natural
preservatives and significant product
effects as I said you need to build
mental cycle and unknown environment
some of the some of the plants and
people planned in other areas in a
commercial sensitive to produce these
essential oils or other botanicals are
actually invasive and other in other
parts of the world so you have to know
the environmental effect of your
supplier in fact there's a surprising
that may surprise some concern
associated it's been buoyed by the UN
regarding some of the botanical products
as they sing here is very poor community
to unreliable environments the
consequences of such risks and the risks
here are shifting from food is these are
talking about subsistence people
subsistence farming folks in for work
for third world countries who are
shifting from food production for their
families to her essential oil production
because they think it's a big cash crop
and the UN says it may be disastrous
because people don't because people
punch they've seen seen localities
plunge into the production essential oil
herbs and if the market crashes if they
if they can't sell it they're left
without food because if their risky cash
crop fields and generally income I want
you to think about that think about nike
and its sweatshops curious if you were a
company would you want to be associated
with this kind of disaster and indeed
i'm sure their organizations have
discovered them that were the case let
me give you an overview this is I'm
going to wrap it up here but I want to
emphasize that you have a due diligence
if you're gonna use natural
it's a growing market and people will
take advantage in the tens of billions
of dollars in the market people need
you've got to control your preserve your
home and you must insist on analytical
specification eating for your botanicals
I know that the herbalists and they're
honest folks will tell you that it's
consistent but what you want are certain
chemicals we've been funded in part to
that then part of that the activity you
need so you need to make sure those are
in every match your receipt and the
level of some of the effective safety
assessments again this is your job you
need to know they have been imprinted
purities and you'll probably get me to
get increasing amounts of data as you go
on the microbiological risk assessment
the most important thing remember this
is the only ingredient added exclusively
for safety you're going to have
decreased advocacy version of that
except you can't just plug it into an
old formula the formula that you made
for a long time it's vetted and say
it'll work it's going to be an atypical
product so you'll probably have to have
a fertile concept of the preservation
and that may mean higher manufacturing
controls it probably will and more
consumer protections in terms of
packaging so again it's not a simple
plug in what your head before you need
to be aware of potential co-financing PR
& PRS use public relations issues again
the positive list and the rest of the
world except in the u.s. is very limited
enlists a lot of preservatives very few
of which are actually using is very few
actually employed and very few of those
are botanicals and lastly safety
environmental and social social mores
not just that they claim that his neck
that is your responsibility as well your
safety the environmental impact and the
social impact we're going to come back
the people who are using the deepest
problem there's like a different IP so
all these things are things that I I beg
you to consider is your due diligence in
this room rock this market will be a
populated it's going to make a lot of
money for a lot of folks and its getting
bigger all the time as you may know some
of the major retailers
and pushing on some of the Big Mac big
house many manufacturers and move away
from some the classic preservatives and
natural preservatives what seemed like a
good place to go because there is a
growing market but it's one that has
some real traps in and remember how
leave you as a final thought that the
preservative is the only ingredient egg
exclusively precision and that's what
you need to be aware of a wrongful these
other things and you'll see that the
references are right here I will go
through all the pages there's maybe 10
pages that talk about natural
preservatives talking about the safety
of them sourcing of them of some of the
watch ounce of energy and be happy to
take any questions thank you for that
presentation dr. Giese we want to get
right to your questions and input so
here's a reminder how does how to let us
know what you have to say questions etc
can be submitted via the Q&A button at
the lower left we will try to get to all
of you but if not we will be sure to
follow up after the broadcast see first
question is coming in so our first
question is from Lilia and MSU and she
asks can the preservatives from the
animal sources be considered as well but
I'm sure he can make a good case for us
really connected I'm not aware of that
but I'm sure you can make a case for
animal source preservatives there is a
concern though you should know that in
many cases in many countries that's
concerned for BSC which is bovine
spongiform encephalitis so much of the
cosmetic industry stopped using animal
derived materials especially names like
tallow because they were worried about
passing on that then the disease
okay our next question is from grin at I
open outcomes and the question is are
there sources of grape seed extract oil
that are quality controlled for
contaminants and what safety concerns
about this derivative are known article
tested a whole bunch of I think was 88
saw receipts a grapefruit seed extract
oil and they found that the only one
that had no adulterants it no parabens
no triclosan note benzethonium chloride
didn't work so I really can't I think if
I not familiar with any and grapefruit
seed extract that actually works at this
is adultery and my track that I would my
personal preference or avoid amateur
okay we have a question from lillian and
it is considering allergic patients how
would you compare natural versus
synthetic preservative in terms of
control quality safety efficacy side
effects and sustainability preservatives
have an own level of sensitization own
level of provoking allergen butcher
allergenic reactions that that's well
known what's not known is is that in
that love the wide range of natural
preservatives but there are a lot of
natural preservative components that are
included in fragrance oils there
recognizes allergens various regulatory
documents especially the EU and the
cosmetic directed so that both of them
can provoke allergy allergenic responses
both of them can certainly elicit
response from those who have been
sensitized and but and these percentages
are known or for the for the synthetic
preservatives and not so well known for
the national treasure that too is is
again something that you have answered
show and some of that is actually
included in the references that I
provided there are no more questions I
would like to once again thank dr. Giese
for his presentation do you have any
final comments dr. Giese it seemed the
most folks in hell that is dangerous but
a preservative it doesn't work it very
dangerous to folks it's cause blindness
because of infection of the person from
contaminated products and as I pointed
out it caused the death of those
children and and it's it's such a large
percentage surprisingly large percentage
of the US and the world that's that's uh
in a compromise it is it's a major
concern so please I appeal to you
whatever preservative you do use make
sure it works because your customer it
isn't risky I would like to thank our
sponsor labyrinth for making today's
educational webcast possible lab rats
calm is the leading scientific social
networking site for more information
visit us at WWDC om today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing on
our website through februari 2016 we
will let you know when it's been posted
and we hope we pass this information on
to any colleagues who couldn't take part
in today's broadcast see you next time
goodbye